President Trump says he's ready for
citizenship for dreamers the Mueller
investigation heats up and should bosses
ever date their secretaries we'll
discuss it this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so it's wild confusion mass hysteria
cats living with dogs the end of the
world as we know it
apparently all this about the Mueller
investigation I'm gonna try and unpack
everything that's going on here because
I think you're hearing a lot of stuff
that's not true from the right you're
hearing a lot of stuff that's not true
from the left basically both sides have
preconceived notions of how this
narrative is supposed to go and they're
shifting the facts in order to meet
those narrative notions we're gonna get
into all of that first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Tommy
John so right now this very instant I'm
wearing my Tommy John underwear and they
are spectacular let me tell you I am so
comfortable I will only buy Tommy John
underwear from now on because that's how
good they are unparalleled comfort
innovative designs patented fabrics they
ensure that your underwear will never
ride up you'll never get a wedgie and
listen as somebody who's two years ahead
in school I know what a wedgie feels
like so let me tell you it's not a great
thing you're never gonna have that again
once you use Tommy John underwear Tommy
John re-engineered underwear so you'll
never have to adjust there are no more
distractions everything stays exactly
where it's supposed to be at all times
which makes it convenient when you're in
meetings because otherwise you look like
some sort of perv so make sure that
you're using Tommy John underwear
because they are awesome
their line of comfortable clothing by
the way also includes undershirts that
stay tucked socks that do not fall down
second skins he's so soft that you won't
believe it
plus a choice of smart fabrics for every
situation or outfit and all Tommy Tron
underwear is backed by their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
so you really don't have anything to
lose hurry to Tommy John calm right now
Tommy John's comm slash Shapiro when you
use slash Shapiro you get 20% off your
first order that's 20% off your first
order when you go to Tommy John comm
slash Shapiro again 20% off when you do
that Tommy John comm slash Shapiro also
use the slash up hero so they know that
we sent you and make sure that that
everything remains where it is supposed
to be it is I'm telling you these
underwear are just fantastic ok so
before I begin with all the negative
news of the day I just want to make a
nice note because I don't normally do
this I'm not big on the emotions I'm not
big on the niceties everything today is
actually a really nice day number one we
get to broadcast from the beautiful
studios here at the blaze so it's very
kind of I'm Glenn backing team to allow
us to use their studio so that's awesome
but also I had an experience this
morning I was up very very early after
my UConn speech last night which went
great it was really it was really fun or
500 people showed up packed house we
would have had another five six hundred
people if they'd allowed in the general
public which they should have and if
they had not warned students that they
required counseling if I even showed up
on campus but
event was just great and I woke up early
this morning I get on the plane and
during liftoff you can't be on the
Internet well not being on the internet
for me is sort of like it must be for a
crack cocaine addict who has no access
so I'm sitting there desperately trying
to reload things on a phone the phone
won't connect to anything and then I
realized hey there's other stuff on my
phone too and so i sat there and i
listened to bach which i downloaded and
i watched videos of my kids on my iphone
on a plane taking off at 400 miles an
hour taking me from Connecticut to
Dallas and I just thought to myself what
a phenomenal world we live in I mean
really it's amazing we tend to overlook
all of this because we're used to it
because this is the civilization in
which we live we take for granted
Western civilization we take for granted
the fact that we live in modernity the
fact that if you have a cold you have
the flu you just run down to a store and
get medicine or we take all this stuff
for granted this stuff is the
painstaking labor of literally millions
of people over hundreds of generations
that's what's brought us to this point
and that's just I think we should sit
back and and marvel a little bit at that
this is the culture that the culture
brought us here right I know that there
are atheists out there who say it has
nothing to do with culture it has
nothing to do with Jo Christian values
it has nothing to do with old-fashioned
Greek reason and-and-and purpose-driven
Telos
that's nonsense okay it's all part of a
whole the reason that you're able to sit
on a plane and listen to Bach write the
music of Bach a religious man on your
iPhone hundreds of years after Bach died
the reason that you're able to sit on a
plane that takes you across the country
in two hours three hours in an attorney
that used to take you weeks this is all
because of free-market capitalism it's
all because of innovation it's all
because there were people who felt
driven to change the world
because yes there was a religion that
was dictating that it was important for
them to change the world to make it
better for other people so all of this
is worth appreciating so that was all
the light stuff now we get to all the
crappy stuff so here we go let's just
jump right in into the Muller
investigation and what's going on with
the FBI so I want to start off by
talking about where the right-wing is
head is at because yesterday I talked a
little bit about some people on the
right who are suggesting that the FBI is
thoroughly corrupt the FBI has been
thoroughly corrupt for years there was
even an implication by a man I greatly
admire of Rush Limbaugh that I was
completely wrong the intelligence
community somehow bamboozled George W
Bush on the Iraq war because I guess
we're just anti FBI now again I thought
that that was silly I think that the
conspiracy theories however are coming
from
certain place the place they are coming
from is the place where we now know that
the FBI was basically complicit with the
Obama DOJ and making sure that Hillary
Clinton was never prosecuted hey Andy
McCarthy who's a pretty level-headed
fellow former federal prosecutor
assistant US attorney he writes for
National Review and he has a column over
at National Review that is really
devastating with regard to the FBI and
the DOJ and their collusion to prevent
Hillary Clinton
from being prosecuted and so here is the
timeline that Andy McCarthy lays forth
because it's pretty it's pretty
astonishing now the reason the Obama
administration protected Hillary Clinton
is because if it turned out that Hillary
Clinton was prosecuted for use it for
for putting a bunch of emails classified
emails on a public server on a server
that was available to him as a private
server but it was available to be hacked
the the reason that this was troublesome
to the Obama administration is of course
Obama had been emailing with Hillary on
this private server and he knew it she
was not using a government email address
so he was implicated in all of this so
here is the timeline as laid out by Andy
McCarthy and it's pretty damning okay
two days after the New York Times broke
the scandal about Hillary Clinton in
March 2015 John Podesta who was then an
adviser to the president and head of
Hillary's campaign emails Clinton
confidant and top state Department aide
Cheryl Mills to tell her that the email
exchanges between Obama and Clinton
should never be disclosed but instead
held because of executive privilege
because they didn't want anybody to know
that Obama had known that Hillary was
using a private email server three days
after that Obama went on national TV and
he lied openly saying that he had only
learned about Hillary's use of private
email quote the same time everybody else
learned it through news reports that was
not true but this set off a series of
panic based reactions among Clinton and
his aides among Clinton and Obama's
aides Clinton campaign secretary Josh
Sherman emailed former White House
director of communications Jen Palmieri
and he wrote Jen you probably have more
on this but it looks like the POTUS said
he just found out HRC was using her
personal email when he saw it on the
news and then Cheryl Mills emailed John
Podesta saying quote we need to clean
this up
he has emails from her they do not say
state gov so what did Obama do well he
had his email communications with
Hillary Clinton sealed so use the the
dubious presidential records privilege
according to McCarthy the White House
insisted that it had nothing to do with
the content of the emails it was just to
vindicate the principle of
confidentiality right they just wanted
to keep things confidential for no
reason for no reason but it's important
to keep things confidential that of
course was nonsense they're trying to
protect
from the implication that he knew that
Hillary was misusing classified
information and then the and then of
course eventually the FBI led her where
Clinton off the Clint had not intended
to harm national security in August 2017
a letter to FBI director Christopher
rate from Senator Chuck Grassley and
Senator Lindsey Graham said quote
according to unredacted portions of the
transcripts it appears that in April or
early May of 2016 mr. Comey had already
decided he would issue a statement
exonerating Secretary Clinton this was
long before the FBI agents finished
their work mr. Comey even circulated an
early draft statements to select members
of senior FBI leadership the outcome of
an investigation should not be prejudged
while FBI agents are still hard at work
trying to gather the facts and then of
course a few weeks after all of that
went down Bill Clinton met with Loretta
Lynch on a tarmac in Phoenix Arizona for
a private meeting McCarthy writes quote
on July 1st amid intense public
criticism of her meeting with Bill
Clinton attorney general Lynch piously
announced you to accept whatever
recommendations the FBI director and
career prosecutors made about charge and
Clinton but of course she already knew
it this time that the FBI was going to
let all of this go right Lisa Paige who
is the paramour of working at the FBI of
Peter struck also at the FBI I'm working
on the Hillary investigation text
instruct quote this is a purposeful leak
following the airplane snafu
since Lynch already knows that no
charges will be brought and finally on
July 5th Comey held the press conference
that started with him saying quote I
have not coordinated or reviewed this
statement in any way with Department of
Justice or any other part of the
government they do not know what I am
about to say that line from Comey was
added after Lynch and Clinton met on the
tarmac and struck acknowledged this in a
text to page on July 1st Lynch timing
not great but whatever wonder if that's
why the coordination language added so
in other words he was very obvious that
the FBI and the DOJ were coordinating to
let Hillary Clinton off the hook before
she was even interviewed and all of this
is devastating to the credibility of the
FBI so when you wonder why it seems that
there are so many people on the right
who are out over their skis with regard
to the FBI's investigation into Bob into
into the president Trump and Trump
Russia collusion the answer is their
credibility has already been called into
serious question because of Obama re
already politicized the FBI and once the
FBI has been politicized it is fair game
to say was it politicized in order to
get President Trump because maybe it
wasn't just politicized in order to
defend Hillary Clinton and President
Obama maybe it was politicized you know
target President Trump so now we have
this narrative that's been set in the
minds of people on the right
the FBI is corrupt it was out to get
Trump and that's why something evil and
terrible is happening right here on the
other side you have a narrative that's
already been set in their minds Hillary
Clinton never under any normal
circumstances could have lost a
president Trump that means the president
Trump only won because Hillary Clinton
was shafted by the Russians therefore
Trump Russia collusion must be real and
the FBI must be absolutely pure in every
possible way Bob Mueller pure Lisa Paige
and struck well you know if not purer
than at least they're trying to do the
right thing and so you have these
counter narratives and they're both
based on what people wish were happening
as opposed to what is actually happening
so in just a second I'm going to talk
about what is actually happening and
President Trump and president from
saying that now he wants to testify in
front of Robert Mueller and why that is
a terrible idea we'll get to all that in
just a second first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at zip
recruiter so it's a new year that means
it's time for you to fire all the people
at your company who suck and hire better
people as it zip recruiter calm is we're
not the firing but the hiring you need
to add new people and zip recruiter comm
will get you the best recruits zip
recruiter post your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards with just
one click and then zip recruiter
actively looks for the most qualified
candidates and invites them to apply
they even review every application to
identify those top candidates so you do
not miss a great match and that's why
zip recruiter is different unlike other
hi ringside zip recruiter doesn't depend
on the right candidates finding you
instead it finds them this is why 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site in
just one day okay zipper core is the
smartest way to hire and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free for free go to zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire that zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire again you get to
post for free zip recruit comm slash
daily wire go and check it out and when
you use slash daily wire that also lets
them know that we sent you so zip
recruit is the best way to upgrade the
personnel at your company ok so back to
the the Muller investigation so
yesterday President Trump was asked
about testifying in front of robert
muller so or Mueller I'm never sure and
President believes Mueller in any case
when the the question has come up
because Mueller apparently wants to
interview Trump himself the reason he
wants to interview Trump is not on Trump
Russia collusion this is where Trump has
it wrong Trump thinks the Mueller wants
to ask him did you cooperate with the
Russians and
Trump thinks well I'll say no and then
everything will be hunky-dory that's not
what Mueller wants at all right in just
the same way that the the FBI did not
actually want Flynn to testify about
Trump Russia collusion they just wanted
to catch Flynn in a perjury trap and
they just want to catch him in a line so
the FBI trap and an obstruction trap
that's what Mueller is doing now he's
trying to set up a pattern or at least
he's trying to find a pattern whereby
President Trump was personally involved
in attempting to stifle the
investigation into Trump Russian
collusion even if the collusion never
took place to understand an obstruction
charge does not mean there was an
underlying crime you could obstruct
justice without an underlying crime
actually taking place it is sort of what
happened with Bill Clinton Bill Clinton
obstructed justice and was involved in
perjury with regard to an affair that he
had not even if regard to an underlying
crime like sexual harassment it was with
regard to an affair he tried to obstruct
justice and committed perjury and lied
to the public about all of this right
that was good enough to get him
impeached in the house Mueller is moving
down the same path right now regardless
of Trump Russian collusion the idea is
that Trump whether he thinks he's
innocent or not it doesn't matter if he
is trying to pressure people into
exonerating him without proper cause and
then he's firing people the idea is that
this is collusion I mean that this is
obstruction rather now as I said
yesterday it's not actually legal
obstruction a legal obstruction is a
very specific thing and we talked about
all the statutes yesterday so if you
missed it go back and listen to
yesterday's show but if you are talking
about the generalized perception of
obstruction which could end in an
impeachment charge by Democrats if they
went back to house in 2018 that's what
mean what are setting up for and that's
why he wants to talk to Trump and that's
why what Trump said yesterday is so
foolish he was asked by the media would
you talk to Robert Mueller and here's
what he had to say you said you really
not have an idea
I'll give you an idea she didn't do it
under
I would do it and you know she didn't do
it under us right if you didn't do it if
you didn't know about ok so here's one
of the problems for President Trump he's
always trying to add to Hillary Clinton
so he says well yeah she talked to the
FBI but she didn't do it under oath I'll
do it under oath okay a couple of things
here one lying to the FBI is a crime
whether you're under oath or not you
don't actually have to be under oath if
you lie to the FBI this is now
considered obstruction and you can be
charged this is what happened to Mike
Flynn he was not under oath when he lied
to the FBI they are charging him with
obstruction of justice anyway and he
could jump to five years in a federal
pen for that right so Trump should not
go in front of Mueller the reason you
shouldn't go in front of Mueller is you
may have noticed that our president is
rather fond of mailing off his rather
fond of making grandiose claims he's
rather fond of saying things that may
not be wholly true well if you step off
the beaten path with Robert Mueller you
are gonna get smacked right Bill Clinton
is a lawyer and a pretty smart lawyer at
that Bill Clinton got caught in
obstruction charges by Ken Starr and
Bill Clinton was very careful I mean
Bill Clinton is so careful that in that
testimony in front of a grand jury he
was asked the whether he is having an
affair with with Monica Lewinsky he said
it depends on what the definition of is
is right because he was trying to parse
is you saying right now I am NOT but
maybe before I did this was made fun of
obviously but that was good lawyering by
Bill Clinton didn't matter he still
ended up in an obstruction of justice
charge the same thing has basically it
could happen here with President Trump
no lawyer worth his salt will allow
Trump to get in a room with Mueller
Trump should not get into in into a room
with Mueller and that is not a defense
of Trump being innocent on any of this
stuff that's just saying if I were
Trump's lawyer there is no way in hell I
allow President Trump to be in a room
with a lawyer or without a lawyer I say
to Robert Mueller you submit to us
written questions and then we will
answer your written questions as we see
fit
right that's what Trump should be doing
now is it good for Trump to say he's
willing to meet and then his lawyers are
just stopping him probably I think that
it's probably good for Trump to say that
but if Trump is taking this seriously
and he actually wants to meet with
Mueller that would be ridiculous that'd
be a mistake I mean you can see how this
would be mistakes he's asked yesterday
that by the press if he if he had if he
had asked Andrew McCabe than the deputy
FBI director and he was at that point
the interim acting FBI director he
supposedly asked McCabe we voted for and
Trump says this in front of the media
about McCabe and asking him we voted for
I don't think so no you don't think you
I don't think I did you don't know I
don't know what's the big deal with that
cuz I would ask you who you who did you
vote but I don't remember that I you I
saw that this morning I don't remember
asking him that question okay I don't
remember asking him that question and no
I didn't are two different answers so
you could actually be charged with
obstruction theoretically if you said no
I didn't ask him that question and then
Andrew McCabe said yes you absolutely
did ask me that question and then Trump
says well I don't remember right the
original answer can be used in an
obstruction charge this is part of the
problem because Trump talks a lot he
could get himself in serious trouble
with the lawyers very very easily no
lawyer including Joe Pesci and my cousin
Vinnie with the full-on clown velvet
suit what allow President Trump to get
in a room with Robert Mueller it would
be the height of stupidity to do this
now as I say and I said yesterday I
think we are on the verge of what could
be a constitutional crisis if Robert
Mueller decides to not indict Trump
because he can't really indict Trump for
obstruction of justice but simply to say
I see a case for obstruction of justice
here it could lead to a serious crisis
where the right says listen it's not
obstruction he can't be impeached on an
on crime and let says all this stuff
looks a lot like sort of commonplace
obstruction and there are no limits in
the Constitution for what you can be
impeached about and so you'll have the
right defending bad behavior and you'll
have the left trying to condemn somebody
or convict somebody based on non
criminal behavior
Alan Dershowitz points this out
yesterday Dersch is more practice lawyer
than iron but he and I come to the same
conclusions on this one what do you
think the investigation is now is it
justice and that would create a
constitutional crisis if the president
were to be charged with obstruction for
simply exercising his constitutional
authority firing Comey telling Comey not
to investigate Flint those are all
within the president's constitutional
authority
okay so intership watts is is correct
about this and it could create a serious
problem now with all of this floating
around as I say there are two narratives
that have been created narrative number
one Mueller must get trump because Trump
is guilty of something and if all he can
get him on is obstruction of justice
then he is the righteous guy he's the
knight on the on the knight in the
shining armor on the white horse riding
in the deus ex machina who's going to
take Trump out of office this is the
narrative from the left the narrative on
the
is that the FBI and Mueller and all of
them are corrupt that they are
thoroughly shot through with corruption
that they are all out to get President
Trump now the leading edge of the spear
here is of course Devin Nunez the the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee and he has come forward with
this four-page memo that supposedly
summarizes all of the problems with FISA
warrants and an Intel gathering in the
Trump Russia collusion investigation the
suggestion being that all of this
investigation has been corrupt from the
very beginning one of the suggestions in
the document presumably is that the FISA
warrant that was originally gathered on
Trump foreign policy advisor Carter page
was gathered based on a the the
so-called steel dossier the fusion GPS
dossier that was funded by Democrats and
may have been filled with Russian
disinformation the idea is that
basically the DOJ and the FBI worked
based on bad information to try and
investigate Trump because the FBI is
corrupt and this goes back to what I was
saying earlier the right believes that
yes by as the FBI is corrupt and was
corrupted by Obama because when it came
to Hillary Clinton
they were so now in Nunez is trying to
put forth this memo and the DOJ is
trying to get Nunez not to put forth the
memo so what exactly is in the memo well
we don't know yet until it's made public
but there's a problem
okay the memo itself is a secondary
concern it's written by a Republican the
real question is what is the underlying
material under girding the memo what is
the classified material on which the
memo is based and the DOJ is saying and
this is the stunning thing the DOJ
Stephen Boyd sent a letter to Devin
Nunez and that letter says in it that
Devin Nunez has not even seen the
classified documents to which he is
referring in the memo so in other words
he's creating unverified conclusions and
then putting them out there for public
consumption here's what the DOJ is
saying quote the committee's memorandum
contains highly classified material
provided by the department to the
committee in a secure facility we
believe it would be extraordinarily
reckless for the committee to disclose
such information publicly without giving
the department and the FBI the
opportunity to review the memorandum and
to advise the H the HPS CI of the risk
of harm to national security and this is
the sentence that matters indeed we do
not understand why the committee would
possibly seek to disclose classified and
law enforcement sensitive information
without first consulting the relevant
members of the intelligence community
seeking committee approval of public
release would require that HPS CI
committee members to vote on a staff
draft memorandum
that purports to be based on classified
source materials that neither you nor
most of them have ever seen you
understand that last part of that
sentence the last part is the is the DOJ
saying you're writing a memo suggesting
that FISA warrants are bad you're
writing a memo suggesting the Intel
community is doing all these things
wrong you haven't even seen the
underlying document which suggests that
maybe Republican if that's true that
means that Republicans are basically
slandering the FBI in an attempt to
defend President Trump because they
think that the FBI is corrupt and
they're looking for evidence to back
that contention so what we have from the
right is the allegation that the FBI is
is filled with corruption from top to
bottom and we have from the left is the
contention that the Republicans are
basically making this up in order to
defend President Trump and on that line
you have Dianne Feinstein the senator
from California and Adam Schiff who are
putting together an alternative memo an
alternative memo that supposedly says
the investigation is doing just fine
that everything is just great now the
Republicans did themselves some real
damage here and I'll explain why they
did themselves some real damage to their
narrative in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Indo Chino so the best suit that
I own the suit that I love the most is
my endo Chino suit I love this unit the
way that I got the suit is I went down
to the Enzo Chino showroom it was it was
down in Santa Monica actually Santa
Monica Boulevard in Beverly Hills I went
there and they fit the suit to you it is
made to order you get to pick all of the
accoutrements on the suit gets pick the
stitching gets picked the buttons you
get to pick the material you get to pick
the lining it's just fantastic it makes
it great Valentine's Day gift for your
hubby or for your boyfriend ladies so
this is where you should go okay you go
to Indo Chino calm you don't actually
have to go to their showroom you can
also send them your measurements and
then they send you a made-to-order suit
you look like James Bond it's just
fantastic you pick your fabric you
choose your customizations you submit
your measurements and then you place
your order and you wait for it to arrive
in three weeks or less and if
something's wrong with it they make it
right you can shop online in Indo Chino
comm or visit any of their showrooms
across North America
this week my listeners get any premium
Indo Chino suit for just 359 bucks
you're paying that much for a suit off
the rack at your local department store
hey you can get that for a custom-made
suit at ENSO Chino calm when you enter
promo code Shapiro's at checkout that's
50% off the regular price for a premium
made-to-measure suit shipping is free
Indo Chino Comm promo code Shapiro for
any premium suit for just 359 bucks plus
free shipping the one that I got is
pretty spiffy it is a three-piece suit
so it includes the vest and
I love the best I have to admit I need
to buy more suits with vests from Enzo
Chino just because I love the vest so
much Enzo chinos calm enter promo code
Shapiro at checkout and get your suit
for 359 bucks
and of course shipping is free use that
promo code Shapiro also to let them know
that we sent you okay so back to our
story the Republicans are trying to make
a case that the FBI is corrupt and one
of the ways they're making the case that
the FBI is corrupt is they're saying the
FBI deleted a bunch of text messages
between Peter struck this guy who's
involved in exonerating Hillary Clinton
and Lisa Paige his paramour both Paige
and struck were married at the time so
these are just classy people all the way
through in any case they were sending
texts to each other thousands of text
messages to each other suddenly fifty
thousand text messages they sent to each
other over the course of over the course
of the last year which is just insane by
the way I'm not sure I've ever sent 50
thousand text messages to anyone in my
entire life so these people were
addicted to text messages and then of
course it turns out that a lot of the
text messages went missing and that
batch of text messages that went missing
included apparently some text messages
from structu page and page two struck
that were deleted between December 2016
and May of 2017 which is a very crucial
period in the life of the of the Trump
Russia probe an investigation it
involves the firing of Mike Flynn and
the firing of James Comey in the and the
investigation of Mike Flynn right that's
a crucial period where you'd really want
those text messages so people on the
right immediately jump to this is some
sort of evil conspiracy why are only
those text messages missing well it
turns out there's a major glitch that
affected virtually all FBI phones so the
original reports that it was a glitch
that affected just these specific emails
was not really true in any case they
should be able to recover those they're
working on recovering those now so
Before we jump to conspiracy inside the
FBI to get rid of all the crucial text
messages we should wait to see if they
can recover them then there is one thing
that I just I can't believe Republicans
did this because it's intensely stupid
and what this was is that Republicans
decided that they were going to make a
big deal out of the secret society text
so what was the secret society text we
talked about it a little bit yesterday
this was the allegation by Ron Johnson
senator from Wisconsin that there was a
text message from structu page or page
to struck talking about a secret society
within the FBI a secret society within
the FBI that was going to take down
Trump and we'd already had a message
from structu page talking about
insurance policy against
from becoming president that one's
actually suspicious but the secret
society this line was repeated all over
Fox News it was repeated all over
conservative talk radio and the creation
of a secret nefarious Society and the
way that Republicans saw the secret
society was like Indiana Jones in the
Temple of Doom they thought that they
were meeting down in some deep dank cave
and people were ripping people's hearts
out it basically went when Peter struck
and Lisa Paige talked secret society at
the FBI looked something like this
and that's what was happening at the
secret society right was Kalima was
happening at the secrets a what now what
it turns out is that the secret society
really wasn't that it looked a little
bit more like this in reality that was
the secret society was actually Revenge
of the Nerds it was not in fact Kali ma
it was just Revenge of the Nerds also
that guy can't play violin that is a
very poor imitation of some playing
violet in any case uh it turns out the
secret society texts were a bunch of
nothing and Republicans made themself
look really foolish or trey Gowdy who's
a very good congressman Republican from
South Carolina here's what he had to say
about the secret society text yesterday
it's right after their lamenting the
fact that Trump Trump won North Carolina
and 81 Florida and they're really
disappointed in the way the election
turned out and then about an inch down
from that is a conversation about
perhaps this is should be the first
meeting of the secret society and then
about to text down they say let's talk
about it with Andy I don't know if
that's Andy McCabe and I'm not gonna
allege that it is but it's eerily okay
so it's all about the secret society the
secret society is something that we
really have to be worried about who the
secret society well unfortunately we now
have the actual text of the secret
society text okay here's what it says
are you even gonna give out your
calendars page wrote to struck in the
text obtained by ABC it seems kind of
depressing maybe it should just be the
first meeting of the secret society
that's a joke folks okay i text with my
friends all the time and we talked about
meeting of the protocols of the Elders
of Zion at our local synagogue making
fun of the idea okay the secret society
is not an actual secret society they're
not getting together to defeat President
Trump now that doesn't mean there wasn't
a nefarious activity inside the FBI but
when you go out on a limb by using the
phrase secret society over and over and
over and it turns out that it was likely
a joke you just make yourself look
stupid you just make yourself look bad
speaking of looking bad in
representative Matt Gaetz is an American
he is an American attorney and
politician who's been the u.s.
representative for
first congressional district since 2017
according to dr. Wikipedia and he was on
with Chris Cuomo last night on CNN and
trying to make the case that there's
corruption in the FBI guys if you're
gonna make the case that there's
corruption in the FBI please do a better
job than this this clip 14 because it
when you're making Chris Cuomo look good
you're doing something deeply wrong here
is it here it is you say that this is
the biggest coincidence since the
Immaculate Conception what are you
talking about the Immaculate Conception
is not how Jesus was born it was the
conception
no no it was immaculate it was Mary's
it was the mother's conception without
original sin it was not the conception
of Jesus facts matter congressman if
you're gonna make an analogy at least
know what you're talking about because
you gotta have a basis for these things
you only know what you show you got to
release that memo it's got to have the
facts and you better figure out what
this secret society is before you say
that there's a shadow organization
within the FBI Chris Cuomo may be thick
as a block of wood but at least he knows
his Catholic catechism from Sunday
school the bottom line is this if you're
going to make serious allegations then
you should be able to support them or
wait for the evidence to come out so
here's my suggestion on all of this
let's just wait for all the evidence to
come out is that so tough could we do
that how about just like wait for some
evidence I know I know I know we want to
jump to conclusions and we want to
determine that the FBI was out to get
Trump or we wanted to determine that the
FBI is completely clean and the
Republicans are out to slander the FBI
don't worry we're gonna find out what
the story is either there's gonna be
something here or there's not gonna be
something here either it's gonna turn
out that there was in fact if I the
application put on based on bad sources
or it's not
and by the way president forum should
release that FISA application I want all
of this stuff released as soon as
possible more public light is necessary
now we need to see all of this material
it is imperative that we see as much of
this material as possible if we do not
see this material then the trust in our
institutions is going to continue to
decline in rather market ways which is
going to be a continuing disturbing
thing so please how about we just wait
for the evidence to come out because it
turns out a lot of propositions can be
true at once it can be true that they're
corrupt people inside the FBI but that
the FBI investigation may not be fully
corrupted it can be true that there's no
Trump Russian collusion but that
obstruction took place or that
obstruction didn't take place but Trump
act in ways that were
it can be true that Hillary Clinton was
exonerated by the FBI in cropped fashion
but that the the investigation at Trump
is still legitimate or it could be true
vice versa we don't know we don't know
we just don't know okay and until we
know I'm gonna hold off on saying that
we know I'm not gonna jump into this is
worse than Watergate until we know
whether it's worse than Watergate I'm
not gonna suggest a missing text
messages which may be recovered and
worse than 18 minutes of tape that are
missing in the Watergate tapes because I
don't know you don't know anyone who's
telling you they know is lying to you no
one knows anything at this point which
is why I'm trying to bring you all the
news and sift through it and bring you
what I think is is actually happening
and where I think this is going in the
end I'm not sure any of this goes
anywhere it seems like much to do about
nothing to me on all sides the FBI
probably is not thoroughly corrupt Trump
probably did not collude with Russia
there probably was no obstruction of
justice and this is all a giant waste of
time and energy if so we have a reason
to be pence but that's a different
reason to be pissed then everybody is
pissed off right now so in just a second
I'm going to discuss whether President
Trump has has betrayed conservatives on
immigration because there are some folks
saying he has done some and defend
President Trump from those charges
because I don't think that's exactly
correct but first you're gonna have to
go over to Daily wire calm right now and
subscribe so first of all you should
just know then when you subscribe you
always get to be part of our mail bags
you also get to be part of you also get
to send us live questions when we do
live events one of those live events is
coming up on the State of the Union day
right Tuesday January 30th next week
we're going to be doing an extra long
broadcast me Andrew Clavin Michael Mills
daily wire god-king jeremy boring rather
than me sitting around talking about the
last year in politics talking about
what's happened talking about what we
expect from the State of the Union we
will watch it together with you MS 3tk
style so we'll comment on it actually
during the during the State of the Union
it'll be lots of fun you will want to
tune in you can do that at Daley
wire.com we'll be mocking each other I'm
gonna try and shave Knowles's head it'll
be a good time had by all
again that's Tuesday January 30th 8:00
p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific and again
when you subscribe to daily we're calm
you can actually send us questions which
we will answer from The Daily wire chat
room follow us on Facebook YouTube get
notified when we go live so we can spend
every terrible moments of the State of
the Union together I hate the State of
the Union duress no matter who is giving
it I think it's an absolute
imperialistic BS nonsense event but
we'll be there and you'll hear me be a
better which I mean hell you're turning
in every day to hear me be better so
three hours of me being better can
what's better than that sounds fantastic
my wife has two
every evening in any case State of the
Union address tune in January 30th 8:00
p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. at Pacific
subscribe at daily wire.com $9.99 a
month you can be part of all of that or
our annual subscription with all of
those aforementioned glories you also
get our world-famous
leftist here's how to recalled tumblr I
didn't bring it with me because it's
just to value to travel with I wouldn't
want to break it it is it is just too
special so make sure that you get your
your leftist here's how to call tumblr
if you just want to listen later go over
to iTunes SoundCloud Google play's
stitcher and subscribe to our channel on
YouTube we always have great new videos
coming out we have some videos that
we're gonna put up for my speech at
University of Connecticut where I am
told there were at least a couple of
thug-life moments so check that out at
youtube.com or and as I say you can
listen on any of these any of these apps
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
all righty so another big news there are
a lot of people who are very hot and
bothered about president Trump's
statements on immigration so let's talk
about what President Trump had to say
about immigration I'm gonna play you the
clip from talking to the press about an
immigration deal that he thinks he's
gonna make with Democrats this is clip
15 Trump talking about immigration with
the press yesterday we want great border
security we want to do a great job with
daca I think it's our issue I think it's
a great better issue for the Republicans
and for the Democrats do you want
citizenship for neighbors we do we're
going to morph into it it's gonna happen
all VAR be over a period over a period
of 10 to 12 years somebody does a great
job they've worked hard
it gives incentive to do a great job but
they've worked hard they've done
terrifically whether they're you have a
little company or whether they work well
whether whatever they're doing if they
do a great job I think it's a nice thing
to have the incentive of after a period
of years being able to become a citizen
I guarantee it because I don't want to
do it you don't want to put a little bit
of it but I certainly have the right to
do that if I wanted these would be chain
migration we're gonna create a standard
that's a good standard so that not
everybody can you know not everybody
that you ever met can come into the
country okay so people are super super
angry how dare Trump say all of this
this is obviously Trump going back on
his campaign promises now unless you
forget trimming a lot of promises during
the campaign and a lot of those promises
conflicted with one another we're gonna
take care of everybody
it'll be an active I mean he said a week
ago we're gonna have a bill of love
Trump says lots of stuff all the time
but the truth is that these dreamers are
not going anywhere okay let's be frank
about this they're not going to be masky
ported the idea that Trump was saying
that dream campaign was always asinine
people who believe that Trump is going
to mass deport 800,000 people who were
brought in here as children are fooling
themselves it was never going to happen
and anyone who believed that was getting
bamboozled as I was saying consistently
during the campaign because it wasn't
true okay Trump was never going to throw
all these people out who's not gonna
throw their parents out he's not gonna
deport 8 million illegal immigrants as
much as Ann Coulter wanted it it was
never going to happen so the Breitbart
too
it's credit I will suggest actually came
out against Trump yesterday because now
the Bandon isn't there I guess they
don't have to lick Trump all the time so
now they actually came out the headline
here's what the headline said at
Breitbart and of course these were his
biggest sycophants right
they say immigration shock amnesty Don
suggests citizenship for illegal aliens
so they're saying amnesty is on now now
is Trump really talking about in amnesty
well he is talking about amnesty in the
sense that these people will get
citizenship after 10 to 12 years but
again that's the direction this was
gonna move anyway so the real question
is what does he get in return for that
it was a foregone conclusion that these
people were not going to be deported and
when Trump says that he may reinstate
daca at the in March what he's really
saying is I may just leave them here
regardless of whether we come to any
agreement what he's pushing for is what
he's already said he is pushing for okay
what he is actually pushing for is an
end to chain migration except for
parents who may or may not receive
citizenship according to Trump we have
no idea 25 billion dollars for building
the border wall for 800 miles of the
border wall so not an entire border wall
along 2,000 miles or anything like that
but 25 billion for building the border
wall and it ends the diversity Visa
Lottery I thought that this was pretty
much the deal that a lot of
conservatives wanted and now he's being
accused of a great betrayal on all of
this because he's talking citizenship
after 1012 years for illegal immigrant
children now the parents should not get
citizenship if they do get citizenship
it should be done based on a on a need
basis right my view on the dreamers by
the way is the same as with their
parents we get to determine who enters
the country and who does not practically
speaking and nobody's gonna deport these
kids or these young adults now it's not
going to happen so they were always
gonna get citizenship Trump was always
going to do it okay I'm just sorry to
break it to you and I mean that's just
the way it was gonna go all of that said
if Trump can get in return for that and
then to chain migration a money for the
border wall and ends the diversity Visa
Lottery that those are pretty
substantial steps in the right direction
those are pretty good steps in the right
direction so this isn't really a bad
deal almost Trump gives full amnesty to
parents who have actually illegally
crossed the border on a blanket basis
because then you're not talking about
just the kids you're talking about all
of their parents and all of their
relatives and all the rest of it that's
something that we obviously need to
prevent if you came across the border
illegally you should not be getting
citizenship if you do get citizenship it
should be because you went to the back
of the line and you waited just like
everybody else and we evaluated you
using the same standards we would for
illegal immigrants but this idea that
Trump has somehow betrayed the trust of
his base I
don't really see that too much now Trump
did make a boo-boo in this interview
right he heard him at the very end say
that he may reinstate daca right you
heard him say that he said it in one
point that that he may actually just
leave people here he may really
Institute President Obama to give
amnesty that's a bad negotiation tactic
dirty little secret about Trump he's
crappy initiation for all the talk about
how Grady is about deal-making he's not
a great deal maker right the last time
you tried to make a deal he cave
directly to Schumer and Pelosi and left
Paul Ryan and and Mitch McConnell with
their pants around their feet the fact
is that he's not good at negotiation his
opening bargain is basically what do you
want maybe I can give it to you it's not
a really good open negotiating stance he
needs to pretend at the very least that
he's going to deport a lot of people in
order to force Democrats to the table
Democrats feel no need to come to the
table instead they've believed that they
can simply pillory Trump and one of
things two things will happen either
Trump will listen to them in which case
they'll get what they want or Trump
won't listen to them in which case they
can continue to pillory him and this is
what Chuck Schumer was doing yesterday
here's the Senate Minority Leader
suggesting that the Tea Party and Donald
Trump by extension are just horribly
anti-immigrant well first the hard right
has always opposed immigration Donald
Trump ran on an anti-immigration
platform the tea parties one of their
fundamental values is anti-immigrant
which is horrible disgusting but that's
who they are okay this is nonsense the
Tea Party's value is not anti-immigrant
the Tea Party was about government
spending I'm not anti immigrants I'm
libertarian on immigration actually if
there's no welfare state if we're not
talking about people voting the fact is
that there's a wide variety of opinion
within the Republican Party about
immigration but the Democrats wants a
pillory Trump is such Trump's done a
good job I think of avoiding that but
when he says that I'm there's no stick
right I'm just gonna reinstate daca if
Democrats don't do anything Democrats
win either way either Trump doesn't
reinstate tack in which case they get
videos of him supporting people or Trump
does reinstate daca in which case they
say we got Trump to surrender without
him gaining anything in the bargain now
that said it is pretty obvious Democrats
don't want to solve the problem and
dreamers are beginning to wake up to
this a lot of illegal immigrant children
are beginning to wake up to the fact
that Democrats aren't actually
interested in helping them here they
just want a posture on it here's an
angry dreamer two Democrats saying
listen we've been waiting for 17 years
why are you making us wait longer than
this when there's a Republican president
a Republican Senate
Republican house that are quite
recalcitrant against dreamers you're not
going to get it all at once for daca
recipients the uncertainty is unsettling
we've waited 17 years already we
shouldn't be waiting any longer okay so
they are getting pressure from their lap
I'm not sure it's enough for them to
overcome the left joy when Trump loses
this is a nice thing about being on the
left if you can do something that hurts
Trump then your base will forgive you
for doing something that also hurts them
and this is a sad truth of politics
hurting your enemy is sometimes more
important than pleasing your base with
policies they actually like if we all
worried about pleasing our base the
policies that we actually like we might
actually get somewhere but politics is
in unfortunately a binary system if
Chuck Schumer can slap Trump across the
head enough of his base will be happy
for that they'll ignore the fact that
the dreamers will still end up in limbo
okay one other quick note that I want to
make so Caitlyn Collins the commentator
on CNN and Jake Tapper played an element
from his show the lead in which Caitlin
Collins suggests that men at work should
never be dating women at work what I've
said all along is that the left has no
consistent standard as to what is
appropriate and male-female
relationships and so now they're trying
to backtrack and create this rather
repressive and victorian new standards
to how dating is supposed to go
here's Caitlin Collins doing that
yesterday and being cheered for in
trouble while releasing this letter
clears things up it doesn't it actually
makes them worse it makes him look even
more embarrassing and creepy and
whatever and let this just be a message
to all of the grown men out there that
though younger women who work for you do
not want to date you they do not want to
be your soul mate they do not want to go
to ice cream with you they do not want
to be your partner and when they start
dating someone else you cannot get angry
with them for that and try to pay them
money to cover it up that is just a
lesson I should not just say that to
people I'm a 25 year old woman I
shouldn't have to say that to anyone
that when a woman goes to work they
don't want to date their boss okay so
let me be clear about this
this is true for the vast majority of
women who go to work it is not nearly
true for all women who go to work okay
the idea that women don't date their
bosses at work is belied by most of
human history if it were not for bosses
marrying their secretaries in the 1950s
an entire generation of people would
okay how many people in this audience
have met their wives at work how many
men are in a position of superiority in
terms of the hierarchy at a company
over the people that they eventually
married a lot okay just because a
hierarchy exists doesn't mean that the
woman is being forced to date the guy
what we want to avoid is the man using
pressure to date a woman but the idea
that every woman may never be asked out
on a date by her boss that of course is
asinine and to this effect I will bring
to your attention one Jimmy a Kimmel I
don't actually knows middle initial I'll
bring to your attention one Jimmy Kimmel
okay Jimmy Kimmel is currently married
to a woman named Molly McNerney hey
Jimmy Kimmel was it was her boss she
started on his show ten years ago as a
writer's assistant and rose through the
ranks and Jimmy eventually started
dating her right eventually they started
dating and then they got married and now
they have a kid together and she says
when I first met him he insulted me the
executive producer brought me into his
office and said this is Molly she's my
new assistant Jimmy barely looked up
from his desk until my EP said she
competes in triathlons and then Jimmy
looked up at me and said that is really
stupid what a waste of time that was
probably probably the first and only
thing he said to me the entire first
year of working there and then Glamour
magazine asked Jimmy Kimmel's wife did
you have any inclination early on this
was a guy you'd eventually marry and
Molly says Jimmy gets a little insulting
when I say this but I never once thought
of him that way or looked at him in that
way I really didn't I'd worked for him
so long and I was in a relationship and
he was in relationships that never
occurred to me and that's workplace 101
you date you don't date your boss except
for how she married him and says when's
did things turn romantic four years ago
all the writers would socialize after
the show and we just hang out more and
more we really liked each other his
friends and then it kind of turned he
cooked for me and that was it it sealed
the deal and she says and one of our
writers meetings because Jimmy is always
thinking about food he asked us what our
five favorite foods were I listed mine
which were Pizza note you know keep it
with no key pasta a BLT crab claws and a
cheeseburger shortly after he had
invited me to his house and I was very
nervous I mean this is my boss and I was
thinking I got to be careful here he
opens the door and the whole house
smelled delicious I walked in and there
was a pizza a BLT crab claws
cheeseburger no key he made them all
from scratch I couldn't believe it and I
realized how incredibly thoughtful and
generous he really was so let me say
something here
hey if Jimmy Kimmel had invited this
woman over and she had not been into it
and had not wanted to marry him the
entire meeti movement would be claiming
the Jimmy Kimmel was responsible for
sexual harassment and abuse of power she
went there and married him so now this
is a great romantic story that gets
retold in Glamour magazine my suggestion
here is that there is no rational
standard that is being held - it is not
the end of the world if a boss invites a
subordinate to a date it is the end of
the world if the
offers consequences for the subordinate
not taking him up on the date right it
is exploitation if it has if it's
exploitation but it is not inherently
exploitation for a boss to be asking a
woman on a date and it just demonstrates
that when you have a lack of moral
foundation you end up creating this
bizarre set of rules that it's more
Victorian than I am okay it's nearly
impossible to be more Victorian than I
am on sex yet somehow the left has
accomplished this magnificent feat so
that is where we are now well tomorrow I
will have a lot more to talk about
Burger King has now joined the left-wing
resistance and is actually putting out
ads against net neutrality we'll talk
about that tomorrow plus I have some
thoughts on the littering Nasr trial but
we will have to get to that tomorrow so
stick around for that i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and arrow
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018